forter une tenue correcte à l'Assemblée
un sujet qui agite l'hémicycle depuis de
nombreuses années je vous demanderai de
vous tenir éloigner de ces extravagances
vestimentaires après avoir porté un jean
et un t-shirt décontracté à l'Assemblée
il y a quelques jours merci il y a Sud
est député elle ETI à une nouvelle fois
fait par les d'elles à cause de cette
tenue une tenue pointée du doigt par
Alain jacubovitz ancien président de la
Ligue internationale contre le racisme
et l'antisémitisme tenue d'hiver d'une
députée on redoute l'été de nombreux
députés de laupestre sont alors indignés
accusant l'avocat de misogynie en lui
demandant de supprimer son tweet face à
la polémique grandissante l'homme a tenu
à s'expliquer je dis simplement que
cette tenue est inappropriée dans ce
lieu alors peut-on venir en tenue
décontractée à l'Assemblée nationale
peut-on venir donner des contracter à
l'Assemblée nationale oui alors oui oui
oui oui bon c'est pas vraiment un sujet
c'est vrai que c'est toujours c'est
toujours les les la France insoumise qui
pose problème Mathieu c'est le widgil
quand je vais l'entendre alors lui c'est
Gilles c'est pas Luigi il faut que je
sois loin de lui parce que c'est loin là
si je m'énerve parce que j'ai rien dit
encore ouais mais ça va être une
connerie à la base tout doit se
respecter il y a des valeurs quand
j'allais au théâtre avec ma grand-mère
elle me disait habille-toi fais-le pour
les acteurs qui sont en face de toi
quand tu vas au César tu mets à nœud
papillon parce que
l'institutions c'est pas pareil
on s'adapte à qui on est en face là
donc encore une fois ils doivent être
chics ils représentent la France dans le
monde entier pour parler je me demande
si elle fait elle est fille est venue
pour faire de la politique ou pour Foot
bordel et s'amuser dans une cour de
récréation depuis qu'ils sont là c'est
une honte et qu'elle vienne
effectivement je pense en jogging est-ce
qu'elle veut c'est c'est quoi le truc
alors c'est totalement
il a raison
de mettre un mec qui aurait dit pareil
il y a des tenues pour les hommes
d'accord maintenant ça a été imposé il y
a un règlement tenu pour les hommes
portent de la veste obligatoire et
cravate recommandées voilà recommence il
y a pas ce genre là et je trouve que
critiquer cette député pour sa tenue
c'est purement sexiste et d'ailleurs
mettre Jacques hubo vite fait une sorte
de pas en arrière parce qu'il se rend
compte qu'il a fait une erreur
monumentale là c'est accusé une femme de
s'habiller comme une femme qu'elle en a
envie mais elle a tous les droits cette
femme
critique par exemple gentiment en se
moquant en 20 ans Daniel Moreau pour
cette nuit sortir en disant Cyril mon
dieu c'est honteux
voilà c'est que je suis là je peux
répondre et moi je trouve alors
je suis d'accord en ce moment c'est
n'importe quoi l'Assemblée nationale et
il faut une tenue ça je suis tout à fait
d'accord mais malgré tout je pense que
si cette dame avait été habillée comme
ça et qu'elle aurait eu le physique de
Kelly ou de Delphine il n'aurait pas
envoyé ce tweet et vous pouvez me dire
ce que vous voulez
je m'excuse
sans humour
je suis assez d'accord avec David je
suis désolé
exactement je suis désolé imagine
Delphine avec cette tenue ça serait pas
ses crèmes et Monsieur Jacky Gauvin qui
a peut-être aussi autre chose à faire
n'aurait pas fait ce tweet excusez-moi
et on commence avec quoi avec le Fond du
Ciel
je suis plutôt d'accord avec Daniel je
suis d'accord avec Daniel au quotidien
et que ça ne dérange personne donc voilà
la phrase t'arrêtes comment ma chérie
[Rires]
comme genre de tenue et je pense que
c'est ça qui l'a choqué je pense pas que
ce soit parce que elle est pas le
physique adaptée comme ça ou que ce soit
une femme bizarre comment elle est
habillé on va pas l'habitude de voir ça
moi je veux dire je vais dire la vérité
moi je je vous allez vous allez dire que
je suis un moi je trouve pas que ça
tenue soit choquant non je suis pas
d'accord même sa tenue je trouve pas ça
moche moi franchement on te dit la
vérité
ça c'est pas non mais c'est pas une
tenue inappropriée
non plus et la société elle a évolué à
Mathieu genre ouais
trucs à Mathieu non mais la tenue elle
est pas je trouve pas qu'elle soit
choquante
c'est juste que c'est en fait on a plus
le droit de vanner en fait pour une
tenue on n'a pas de valeur n'a pas le
droit de dire qu'on n'aime pas une tenue
on a pas le droit d'avoir du goût on n'a
pas on n'a pas le droit de dire que ça
c'est pas bien ou c'est fin tu vois
c'est un problème la manière dont il a
dit qu'il y a assez étrange on arrête de
dire tenue correct exigée parce que
chacun a sa façon de penser que tenue
est correcte pour qui c'est un jogging
et d'autres c'est une cravate
l'Assemblée nationale ça doit être pour
les femmes une tenue pour les hommes une
tenue que la société c'est comme ça plus
personne quasiment plus personne n'est
costume aujourd'hui ça a changé ils sont
censés représenter la société qui soit
dans la provocation oui d'accord ça
c'est choquant mais là elle s'habille
tout à fait correctement elle a le droit
de s'habiller comme elle veut non mais
bien sûr
je suis désolé
mais c'est pas un chat
c'est un style c'est genre un short avec
des couleurs
alors quoi c'est les filles en robe à
l'Assemblée nationale et les mecs en
costume qui dit pas de bêtises non plus
tu dis n'importe quoi là tu dis d'abord
c'est pas venu avec une tenue on voit
aller aller à la poêle ou un truc comme
ça mais pas aux femmes alors c'est du
sexy
il y a une femme qui vient habiller
comme afidaq j'adore qui est très
sympathique quand elle vient sur le
plateau mais là oui là on dira bon c'est
vrai que bon pour la santé ils ont pas
le droit
quand tu seras dans la mode tu pourras
me parler quelque chose d'important
mais pourquoi les hommes on leur a
obligé un costume une veste obligatoire
et pourquoi les femmes c'est libre de
dire des choses aux femmes
merci à la raison moi c'est François
Ruffin qui avait été venu avec un
maillot de foot un maillot de foot à
l'Assemblée et ils avaient dit
maintenant faut mettre des bas faut
mettre des barrières maintenant vous
allez venir avec des vases vous allez
venir bien habillé et pour cette dame là
moi je dis que l'Assemblée nationale il
faut respecter quand même le cadre il
faut respecter les institutions si on
ouvre une porte à venez en basket et en
short après bah venez plus en basket
venez en tong venez plus en short mais
venez merci partout dans tous
les regardez on a un méconton là on a un
mec on tombe bah vas-y bah mettez-le si
vous me dites que vous l'avez me dire
vous l'avez si vous l'avez pas Cyril
sera chaud ils ont qu'à venir à
Marseille dans tous les métiers tu dois
t'habiller et je dis pas ça parce qu'on
a eu des problèmes avec eux les mecs il
y a un problème quand même et tous les
problèmes que ce soit avec la France
insoumise je suis désolé les mecs
excusez-moi de vous dire ça tous les
problèmes à l'Assemblée c'est la France
insoumise je suis désolé alors Gilles
Verdez je sais que ce sont tes tes amis
m'excuse moi j'ai le Verdez tes amis je
moi je suis d'accord avec Gérald
Darmanin il participe à la bordélisation
de la société d'accord et à l'Assemblée
je suis désolé excuse-moi tous les
problèmes viennent de c'est un truc de
fou ça c'est incroyable c'est c'est
c'est on est d'accord ou pas bien sûr et
moi je pense qu'ils sont quand même dans
la dans la provoc aussi donc voilà
cette jeune femme moi je suis rien
contre sa tenue mais c'est encore voilà
c'est voilà c'est toujours voilà c'est
c'est ça ça c'est de l'anarchie en fait
il y a des métiers où tu dois respecter
il y a des métiers où tu dois être
habillé d'une certaine manière par
exemple notre Cyril est-ce qu'on peut
venir habiller comme on veut nous ici
alors ça mauvaise exemple
est-ce que demain moi je peux venir avec
le survêtement de l'équipe de France bah
oui tu peux venir là-bas
non mais c'est vrai qu'on peut venir
comme on veut
demain Cyril j'ai avec un débardeur on
ne peut pas j'adore métier d'image c'est
génial monsieur
toi tu viens débardeur c'est bon
Jean-Marie vient en débardeur je lui
demande de pizza
bien sûr
tu avais des invités tout à l'heure à la
grosse moi je voulais venir en pige ça
me facilitera la vie sauf le fait pas
pour respect des gens justement pour
rejoindre monsieur
tout à l'heure tu avais des invités
regarde tu t'es habillé classe par
l'aspect pour tes invités
parce que l'après-midi mettre que des
trucs comme ça en fait si je peux me
permettre
ça éviterait personnel je vous préfère
comme ça pour faire TPMP
personne n'a aucun respect pour personne
rien habillé comme on veut c'est ça la
liberté
nationale quand tu t'habilles Jean-Marie
tu t'habilles pas pour toi tu t'habilles
pour ceux qui vont te voir donc la tenue
que tu mets c'est pour l'autre
pour toi pour les autres disaient les
hommes qui s'habillent en jogging sur
les gens qui se laissent aller pas parce
que c'était pas pour toi
110 ans qui se laissent aller c'est
vraiment il t'avait mis à part dans la
phrase
sauf si elle est là tout ça il est sympa
c'est d'un autre monde j'en ai marre je
comprends pas qu'il y a encore des
endroits en France où on soit obligé
d'être en veste en costume c'est du 10e
siècle c'est fini
[Rires]
moi je vais venir livrer je vais venir
te livrer avec la combinaison de borax
de la beauté etc donc des fois on est
obligé d'imposer quelque chose pour que
chacun soit de ce n'est pas différente
excusez-moi
à l'endroit dans lequel on se trouve
donc être habillé d'une certaine façon
comme je disais
je peux dire un truc c'est que le
smoking c'est d'où ça vient ce sont les
gens dans les soirées qui n'avaient pas
qui étaient souvent honoré par des
militaires qui avait leur costume
d'apparat ceux qui n'avaient pas de
costume d'apparat avec donc un smoking
c'est pour dire que il respectait tout
le monde donc on avait décidé d'un
uniforme sobre mais classe toi pour être
au milieu de ceux qui avaient des sympas
mais nous apprend